the truth is out there with thousands of
sightings theories and believers the
creature known as Bigfoot has become the
stuff of legend what if this fabled
cryptid was doing more than lurking in
our imaginations
what if Bigfoot was actually real
where did Bigfoot come from what secrets
would it reveal and could it really be
out there this is what if and here's
what would happen if Bigfoot exists when
Roger Patterson and Bob Gimlin shot a
few seconds of film possibly showing the
legendary beast in Humboldt County
California it sparked the imagination of
thousands but Bigfoot lurked in the
minds of the curious long before the
patterson-gimlin footage variations
around the world include the Sasquatch
Yeti skunk ape yowee and wild man but
what was it really Wow Bigfoot sure is a
catchy name the creature would need some
better identification than that a
popular theory suggests that Bigfoot is
closely related to the long extinct
Gigantopithecus a distant cousin to the
orangutan that lived throughout
Southeast Asia
Gigantopithecus stood over three meters
tall and weighed up to 270 kilograms
little is known about this mysterious
giant which only adds to the Bigfoot
myth researchers have however managed to
find sets of teeth and partial jaws
studies of these chompers have given us
some insight into the Gigantopithecus
lifestyle it's believed that prior to
its extinction the Gigantopithecus lived
on a diet of fruits leaves and roots all
things it could find in its native
homeland but is it possible the giant
ape could have migrated maybe to avoid a
predator
or because of climate change what if the
strange sightings of Bigfoot were a
result of this creature crossing the ice
bridge to North America with its
descendants evolving into a separate
species or maybe the Bigfoot has a
little more in common with something
else you you even with all your
sophisticated human traits come from the
same family tree as animals this line of
thinking leads to the idea that in order
for us to have broken off from our
primate roots there must have been a
middleman or more appropriately a
missing link in the 1990s the concept of
a molecular clock was developed this
technology proves that molecules are
constantly shifting and changing the
older the split between different
species is the more molecular
differences that are going to be using
this molecular clock idea blood from
humans and gorillas was sampled and it
was found that we shared a common
ancestor about 11 million years ago
could Bigfoot be what researchers call
our last common ancestor well the search
for our missing link still exists and
the search doesn't look like it's going
to be that easy many people worry that
if the last common ancestor actually is
found we won't even be able to recognize
it so is it possible Bigfoot could be
lurking out there while it's easy to
dismiss Bigfoot sightings as a hoax
there were 71 new species discovered in
2019 alone
so it isn't unreasonable to state that
we don't know about everything that
lives on earth
in fact many well-known species like the
giant panda the Komodo dragon and the
mountain gorilla were all discovered
because of their connection to folklore
while Bigfoot may continue to be the
all-time greatest hide-and-seek champion
the search for it could lead to
discoveries of new species or new
insights into our own evolution we're
discovering new creatures every year so
we shouldn't give up our hunt for
Bigfoot the whole purpose of science is
to be continuously on the lookout for
something new that we didn't know before
our advice to you don't stop believing
if Bigfoot is ever found though he would
open up a Pandora's box like what other
mythological creatures could be out
there what if in the deeps of the ocean
the Kraken was prowling well that's a
story for another what if
[Music]
you